sting I told you don't call me at work
man later all right dude Jesus
Christ hello my name is Stuart copel and
I'm here to answer your questions from
the internet this is drummer
[Music]
support at download music Z doesn't
matter how you hold your drumsticks uh
we all have our preferences I favor
Orthodox technique like this voila most
drummers today play match grip Gua the
reason I play like that is because I'm
old school the snare drum derives from
marching bands and when the soldier is
marching with a snare drum between his
legs it clonks his knees so he turns it
on an angle so to try and play like that
is a problem so they play like that
which is a much more natural position at
Sydney alligood what is the hardest song
to drum I would say sister sad by Buddy
Rich some challenging stuff on there in
my music my spirits in the material
world it is my personal bet Noir and
it's because there's no one it's all up
[Music]
be 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 2 three 4 two it's
all upbeats at Val Ambrose hello I'm a
beginner at drumming do you have any
tips that could help me out that is what
we're here for today learn to fill in
with the Rhythm you don't need a drum
set just listen to records and tap on
your knees that's step one and
everything else derives from that posted
by you drummer Wayne 101 why are the
police hard to play because of
Stuart you just answered the question
right
there you smart at liit SL joojo
musicians what does playing in the
pocket mean to you how do you achieve
that the pocket is when musicians are
locked to each other's pulse it just
feels good like in the Rolling Stones a
great example of just it's all messed up
it's loose it's ramshackle it's cow W
but they've got that pocket they're in
sink with each other in an elemental
organic way that is the pocket and a
pocket is the Holy Grail of all Ensemble
playing at mod drummer what is the best
way for a new Drummer to get better at
playing drum fills a drum fill is um
when you're playing
along here's a drum
[Music]
fil practice slow to achieve speed if
you're just going as fast as you
can you know you're not going to play
perfectly but if you concentrate by
playing
[Music]
slow you're focusing on getting both
hands even and you're doing it
absolutely a comfort able speed so that
you can execute perfectly so when you're
practicing always be perfect when you're
on stage you don't have to give a
because you're just making the up
if you're thinking about being perfect
you're just going to be lame at
jockes
Q D while in the Beatles was Ringo Star
a good drummer or merely a competent
drummer he was a very good drummer he
had an excellent Groove a Groove is when
the music hangs together in such a way
that it's not just correct but it makes
your hips move and he was very
imaginative in the way he used drums in
a pop song you can find online three
versions of The Beatles first song Love
Me Do and there is a version with their
original drummer Pete best it ain't the
Beatles it's just like kind of lame it
doesn't hang together then there's a
version with Ringo
[Music]
Star
okay we're now the Beatles but then for
some unknown reason they hired a session
drummer and Ringo is now on
tamine and as you listen it you realize
the Charisma in the Rhythm isn't on the
drum set anymore that's just some
session guy the Charisma is just the
tambourine part has got a Vibe and
that's Ringo it's Vibe it's X Factor
it's undefinable in fact music is the
only art form that will usurp motor
control of your body on the Dance Floor
people are in public thrusting their
pudenda at each other in an overt sexual
display try that without music you get
arrested at Mike Reno favorite reg Song
reggae song with the most creative drum
Andor most impressive drumming Lively up
yourself by Bob Marley and the Whalers
but another one a seal piece was the
Israelites by Desmond Decker and that's
the first time I ever heard heard the
bass Awards reggae drum figure cool
thing about reggae drumming is it's a
drum solo all the way through they never
stop they're just playing some R in
[Music]
here they're they're always playing
something in contravention of the pop
rules of respect for the vocals the
vocals at Mark lanon do drum kits need
tuning yes you can change the sound of
your drums I I tend to go by tuning them
up and a little word of advice for bands
is when you're doing your sound check
and you're going
boom okay second rack
TomTom and they sound huge by
themselves but as soon as the band kicks
in they disappear by tuning them higher
they may sound a little they may sound a
little rinky dinky without the rest of
the band but as soon as the other music
fills in they cut through at Bern this
town no seriously how do you learn songs
on Drums by ear you don't you just bang
yes by ear by Instinct and if you
are musical you will know when 16 bars
are up when eight bars are up or
whatever and musical memory is a very
very strange thing it's much better than
any other form of memory you can forget
people's names you can forget what you
learned in geography class but for some
reason you learn how to play a tune and
it lasts forever when the police did a
reunion tour I haven't even listened to
those songs for 30 years and I get my
practice real okay let's see if I can
remember how to do this I knew
everything note perfect 30 years later
at tones of Music who's the best drummer
you've seen Live Well Buddy Rich uh
Mitch Mitchell there's a lot of drummers
that I really like that aren't famous
names they just have a great lope they
just have a great feel to them Taylor
Hawkins just had a great feel to him
Ringo Star Charlie Watts no chops there
but just that Groove is way way cool now
on the younger end of it I would say
Joey jordison sadly Departed with
sliping on that little bastard had chops
you know kids these days they start out
where we left off and it's like the
Olympics where every year they can jump
a little higher run a little faster
how's that possible has the human
species evolved in one year I don't know
but Joey jordis doing things with his
feet that I aspire to with my hands I am
the law how is drum music written is it
like standard music yes it is exactly
the same music only without pitch often
percussion scorers and drum scorers will
use lines they'll be a line just for the
snare drum rat tat tat tat and it has
the same note values 16th note eth note
and what have you from coach serious
question for drummers do y'all feel it
when y'all be speeding up or no actually
no it may feel like the world is slowing
down but of course one's subjective
concept of tempo mind being particularly
shifty is that you feel like you're just
doing what's perfect for instance with
Police songs some of them we had a click
you know for a handful of the police
songs the reason we did that was because
I'd speed up when it goes into the
chorus but with the click wow the
sensation is that the track just slowed
down and you got to be kidding that that
click just slowed down what's the matter
with you click I'm human this is my
rhythm Tempo is very subjective MDX
v111 all are there any rules to adding
swing to Drums well my daddy was a jazz
musician he used to complain about the
music that I listen to cuz where's the
swing if it don't swing It Don't Mean a
Thing uh dad there's all kinds of music
that doesn't swing but really swing is a
specific kind of Jazzy sort of
feel it just sort of has a feeling of a
shuffle to it it's
not
it's it's not it's what you could call a
dotted Rhythm or or a swing Rhythm or a
shuffle at metal Walden favorite odd
time signature and why I don't like odd
time signatures because basically it's
like a hiccup you know the old joke of
how do you conduct five four time one
two 3 4 One 2 three four I guess take
five by Joe MLL is one of those
religious experiences that every drummer
needs to have it's kind of the most
wrongest form of jazz
ever
[Music]
it's Sublime posted by
you/ Timmy own any tips for playing fast
punk rock pop punk I guess the
fundamental thing that keep in mind is
to play it fast a way to achieve speed
is to relax really the vibe you want
metal drummers are even fast
[Music]
that muscle up eat your weedies and just
play it faster this is from Bill hater
hey music nerds I'm trying to understand
the concept of poly Rhythm poly rhythm
is uh when you play two rhythms at
once that's one
rhythm
it just means a lot of Rhythms on top of
each other that kind of contrast with
each other well students this is all I
have for you today eat your weedies do
your homework and drum
[Music]
on